welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and it chapter two
is it chapter two hours and 49 minutes
of jump scares gross outs random music
cues but most importantly for us here at
nr
and exploding dairy factories worth of
easter eggs horror film references
cameos nods to stephen king's other
works and super creepy pennywise
sightings all over the background
because he's everywhere at all times so
let us go back through it chapter 2
scene by scene for all the details that
you might have overlooked and spoiler
warning if you haven't seen it yet
though
it has seen you the film opens with
what's actually the opening seat of the
novel
the violent murder of adrian mellon a
gay man on his way back from the dairy
carnival king actually based this attack
on the real-life murder of charles o
howard in
bangor maine in 1984. howard was
assaulted by three teenagers and thrown
off the state street bridge
melon is actually played here by one of
the many director cameos throughout the
movie xavier dolan canadian director of
art house films and actually adele's
hello music video stephen king used to
live in bangor and he based dairy on
this location
probably haunted by the rage of its
citizens when he pronounced its name as
banger melon wears an i heart dairy
beaver hat which the bullies steal
and it's adapted from the iheart dairy
shirt that he wears in the novel we also
saw the phrase printed on the balloon
when pennywise kills patrick in chapter
one
adult mike hanlon isaiah mustafa arrives
at the crime scene and realizes it has
returned
and he calls each of the losers to
return to dairy of the losers stanley
yuris takes his own life
by slitting his wrists in a bathtub
shortly before this we see him doing a
puzzle depicting a bird
a nod to stanley being an avid bird
watcher in the novel in the 1990
miniseries bill denborough james mcavoy
is now a novelist adapting books into
screenplays
keeping up the stephen king tradition of
king writing surrogates of himself into
his work the shining in misery also
focused on writers and there's this
running joke that bill's endings suck
a nod to the common criticism of king's
book endings the movie that bill's
working on is being directed by
legendary filmmaker peter bogdanovich
director of the last picture show
of whom it director andy muschietti is a
big fan here we also meet bill's wife
audra who actually plays a much bigger
role in the it novel
in which she follows bill to dairy and
ends up getting kidnapped by a pennywise
controlled tom
beverly's abusive husband and speaking
of her mike also calls beverly marsh
jessica chastain as she packs her bag
and prepares to leave
[ __ ] tom there's a moment where the
camera follows her back into her closet
where you can see the curtain shaking
ever so slightly the folding material
makes it look
just like pennywise it's pant leg
telling you he's everywhere at all times
and there's another cameo in the
introduction of adult ben hanscom
jay ryan now a successful architect on a
conference call one of the other
developers he's chatting with is a cameo
by brandon crane who played
young ben in the 1990 miniseries ben
argues against dividing up this new
building with interior walls
wanting it to be open to bring people
together foreshadowing the final act
in which the losers must come together
and the way pennywise screws with ben
burying him alive in the imploding
clubhouse that he built then
we need the adult eddie casparack james
ranson and he's seen driving
actually kind of a fake out nod to his
line of work in the novel he runs a
limousine rental company in the movie
here he's a risk analyst
eddie argues with his wife mira played
by molly atkinson
one of my favorite details here she's
the same actress who plays his
mother sonia see sometimes he can just
use the magic of cinema
and simple casting to burn your mama's
boy characters richie tozzier bill hader
is a stand-up comedian
changed from the la radio disc jock he
is in the book his manager is yet
another cameo
screenwriter jason fuchs co-writer of
wonder woman they reunited a chinese
restaurant and as they stand outside ben
asks bev if there's a secret password to
get in a callback to her line to him
as kids when they first met you can let
me go by or is there a secret password
or something
here pennywise terrorizes them with
fortune cookies first with the phrase
i guess stan couldn't cut it nice
wordplay there and then of course with
the cookies hatching open into
horrifying little monstrosities then as
they leave the restaurant richie gets
approached by the little kid dean
played by luke rossler who actually
played young david holler in legion on
fx
and poor dean gets screamed at by adult
strangers several times in this movie
then
mike drugs bill and explains its origin
shown through visions passed on from a
native american tribe
imagery hints that the entity arrived to
earth from space in prehistoric times
terrorizing and preying upon generation
after generation of indigenous tribes
before the written history that ben
researched in the first film
mike also proposes the ritual of truth a
ritual that plays out quite differently
in king's novel i explain all that in
another video go check it out the adult
losers revisit their clubhouse that ben
dug out for them as kids
there they retrieved the hair net that
stanley made them all wear which he gave
to them to protect against spiders
foreshadowing its final form as a giant
spider
in this flashback ben plays new kids on
the block music and there's a poster of
the film the lost boys
with a similar kids rallying against
supernatural threat concept as
it has also this makes the second lost
boy's reference for a horror film this
year jordan peels us also alluded to it
in its opening scene elsewhere in this
movie's opening acts you see the image
of rushing water flooding the barons the
imagery is pretty similar to the rushing
blood flooding the overlook hotel in the
shining
it spits out henry bowers who we thought
died in chapter one but pennywise spared
him
used him to take the fall for all the
crimes and now as an adult pennywise
frees henry bowers from criminal mental
institution and uses him to attack the
adult losers meanwhile each of the
losers re-explore their memories and
search for artifacts
to burn in this ritual bev returns to
her old home now occupied by an old
woman named mrs kirsch who is of course
pennywise in disguise he's everywhere at
all times before things get super
obvious there are a few clues to this
trickery right away when they first
greet each other
the name on the door switches between
marsh and kirsch and of course mrs
kirsch has a weird thing about long
creepy stairs but
most discreetly when the door first
creaks open and mrs kirsch is still in
the shadows
her voice is actually being dubbed by
bill skarsgard in this moment
yes mrs kirsch's transformation into
pennywise becomes less and less subtle
there's a moment when bev gags on the
tea
mrs kirsch goes to take cookies out of
the oven these both could be hints to
the slightly different way this scene
plays out in the book where bev's tea
actually turns into raw sewage and mrs
kirsch turns into the witch from the
hansel and gretel stories one of bev's
childhood fears
and the music that miss kirsch puts on
here is a 1943 danish song called
forgive my pronunciation danes
day a day schnitzel translating to it's
the most beautiful thing i know by max
hansen there's just something about the
orchestration of songs from that era
it's just too evocative of
midnight the stars in you the song from
the shining and while creeping on bed
from the kitchen
kirsch tells her a narrative about her
father a circus clown named bob gray
bob gray actually showed up as an easter
egg in chapter one
along with pennywise he's one of the
entities many favorite incarnations
kirsch's unsettling nudity as she
shapeshifts is a tactic by pennywise to
trigger
bev's trauma from sexual abuse as a kid
from her father as a child and now as an
adult her husband and then moving on to
ben's memory trip that takes him back to
their school
with a flashback with bev you probably
noticed her shadow in the slide
projector takes the shape of pennywise
could be a nod to pennywise jumping out
at them from the projector screen and
that's seen in chapter one
bev's hair catches fire and she
transforms into pennywise a nod to the
line and bends poem
your hair is january embers pennywise
uses these words to taunt ben
and he says kiss me fat boy from one of
the best moments in the 1990 miniseries
kiss me fat boy in this classroom on the
desk is a statue of a
turtle if you read this book in a number
of kings other works you probably
recognize this as a nod to the giant
turtle from the macroverse
the turtle's name is maturin he's a
benevolent entity
the enemy of it he vomited up the earth
in ancient times and now he carries it
on the back of his shell
i know it doesn't totally make sense
it's just kind of one of those things
and here in the movie the shot of him is
framed
with a globe behind him very nice
by the way to prepare for this breakdown
it helped to brush up on stephen king's
novel which in case you didn't know
is massive of course they made into two
movies or the second one being nearly
three hours long because this thing's a
freaking doorstopper i just don't have
the upper body strength to prop up even
a paperback that long so i was so
grateful to audible which i used to
listen to the it
audiobook thank you to audible for
sponsoring today's video audible has the
world's largest selection of audiobooks
and audio entertainment including
audible originals
stories created exclusively for audio
including documentaries exclusive
audiobooks and scripted shows you can't
hear anywhere else they offer the
convenient audible app where you can
listen on any device so that you can
have stephen king's imagery haunting you
at the gym or while shopping commuting
or walking alone in a sewer just kidding
why would you ever do that
audible members can choose one audiobook
every month regardless of price as well
as two audible originals from a fresh
selection
and members can keep their library of
listens forever and can easily exchange
any title at any time start listening
with a 30-day audible trial and your
first audiobook plus two audible
originals
are free just go to audible.com
newrockstars again audible.com
new rockstars a-u-d-i-b-l-e.com
n-e-w-r-o-c-k-s-t-a-r-s or text the word
new rock stars to 500-500
okay back to adult ben here when he runs
out of the school with his artifact the
yearbook page that bev signed he runs
into a custodian
apparently this part was going to be
played by director gamer del toro
mentor to mushieri from their time
working together on mama but it ended up
being a whole thing so they scrapped it
richie meanwhile visits the capitol
multiplex cinema where a poster from the
90s rom-com you've got mail appears on
the wall
the second meg ryan referenced in this
movie after adrian mellon's haircut disc
in the movie theater's arcade there's
another poster that is torn in a
specific way to leave the letters
i and t visible everywhere at all times
the title on the marquee outside is
nightmare on elm street five the dream
child
another horror nod actually the
supernatural boogeyman freddy krueger is
pretty similar to pennywise if you think
about it they both target kids they can
pop up anywhere now in the novel richie
bev and ben
see a screening of i was a teenage
werewolf at this movie theater they get
a fight with henry bowers where they
throw popcorn at him but here the
flashback has changed
so that it reveals something new about
richie for this movie that he had a
crush on a boy so richie's artifact is
the arcade token from that memory
richie's closeted sexual orientation
is the dirty little secret that
pennywise refers to that's why adrian
mellon's corpse reappears here
passing out missing person flyers
showing richie then outside adult
ritchie is attacked
by the paul bunyan statue come to life
and that statue is based on a real
bunion statue in bangor
if you think about it paul bunyan is a
manifestation of masculinity
something richie feels insecure about
and this scene was originally not in the
chapter 2 script but stephen king asked
the filmmakers to include it meanwhile
eddie revisits the pharmacy where he got
his inhaler and if you look closely in
one of the aisles in the background is a
cameo by director andy muschietti eddie
goes down to the pharmacy basement
as one does where he's attacked by
pennywise in leper form
and vomits into his mouth to the most
random angel of the morning music cue
ever what is his deadpool anyway during
all this bill goes to the second hand
rose antique store where the clerk
is wouldn't you know it stephen king
himself he gets in another
self-referential dig about bill's
unpopular book endings now bill is
looking for his old bike
silver which he named after the lone
ranger's horse which is why while he
rides it later on he cheers
hyo silver away but in this scene bill
also says silver is quote
fast enough to beat the devil a nod to
the losers using pieces of the metal
silver
against pennywise believing silver to
have the anti-supernatural
properties that silver does against
werewolves and if you look closely in
this antique shop there's a license
plate reading
cqb241 which is the license plate of the
killer plymouth fury from stephen king's
novel christine
later bill passes the dairy historical
mural of the gang shootings
which we saw a shot of earlier and it
looks normal but
when he passes it again it once again
has pennywise snuck in under the car of
that mural
just like he did in that creepy shot in
chapter one bill revisits the sewer at
jackson witchum where georgie died and
he runs into the kid dean again
dean's skateboard has a familiar pattern
on the back it's the same pattern of the
carpet and the overlook hotel
later bill goes to rescue dean from the
fun house of the carnival inside there's
some swinging clowns
designed to look like the tim curry
pennywise from the 1990 mini series now
for bill the trauma pennywise exploits
is bill's survivor's guilt his fear of
letting a younger kid die while he feels
helpless to do anything about it so
after pennywise kills dean in the
funhouse bill takes the active step by
going to the knee bolt house alone
but after dealing with henry bowers the
rest of the group joined him as well
now inside the neighborhood house bev at
one point says beep beep richie they
catch phrase from the novel to get
richie to shut up whenever he won't stop
doing bits but then the fridge opens up
revealing stan's severed head spews out
spider legs
richie says you gotta be kidding me it's
an homage to the iconic moment from john
carpenter's the thing when the alien
shapeshifter does the same move with a
severed head you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding the losers descend into
the cavern
attempt the ritual by burning each of
the artifacts but it doesn't work this
simply
a red balloon inflates the dead lights
come down and pennywise emerges as a
giant spider but still with the bill
skarsgard pennywise face
and torso and he taunts them with the
line what was it gazebos
he's calling back the line from the
first movie when eddie tries to call out
his mom
for sickening him with placebos see what
these are
they're gazebos the losers are scattered
into their own personal hells
richie and eddie arrive back at the
three doors not scary at all scary very
scary
behind one is the pomeranian dog that
they referred to earlier behind another
is the severed bottom half of a woman
this is another callback this woman's
severed top half was behind one of the
doors in chapter one
bill finds himself back in his flooded
basement where he realizes the georgie
he's been talking to is a puppet
controlled by his own arm kind of
reflects how his guilt over georgie is
actually his own subconscious own
anxiety weighing him down beverly's back
in the bathroom stall the first place we
saw her in in chapter one
on the wall with some graffiti including
the name greta which was the name of the
pharmacist's daughter the girl who
bullied bev here the stall door pushes
open with bev's father alvin trying to
get in and at one point henry bowers
pushes through he says here's johnny
shining reference yeah you get it but
they all managed to shake it off and
they confront pennywise but
eddie dies in a heroic self-sacrifice
they all use their confidence over fear
to make pennywise smaller insulting him
with childish slurs pennywise reacts by
desperately shape-shifting in various
forms
including briefly that of the flute lady
from stanley's memory and they all chant
you are the clown until pennywise
shrinks and shrinks and shrinks down
to i guess a kind of a melted doll and
he dies they escape the collapsing
cavern in the kneebold house
they wash off in the quarry that they
played in his kids where richie sobs and
they all hug it out this is also
symbolically washing away the evil
because remember in chapter one they
talked about seeing a turtle in this
water
perhaps a sign that these cleansing
waters are connected
to the benevolent turtle spirit that
watches over them the reveal of
stanley's heartfelt final words narrates
the final minutes which feature richie
carving his and eddie's initials in a
post and there's one last cool easter
egg here
bill is writing his next book but the
paragraph visible on his computer screen
is actually a direct quote from the it
novel
the scene where eddie's mom drags him
away from the others and says these were
his friends
and his mother was wrong they weren't
bad friends maybe he thought there
aren't such things as good or bad
friends
maybe they're just friends people who
stand by you when you're hurt and who
help you feel not so lonely
maybe they're always worth being scared
for and hoping for and living for no
good friends no bad friends
only people you want need to be with
people who build their houses and your
heart
oh what was the most frightening
numerator chapter two for you comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on twitter and instagram at eat
and subscribe to new rockstars for more
in-depth breakdowns of the things that
you love
thank you for watching and thank you to
this film for showing me that there's
nothing wrong with making cookies naked
who has the time to dress when they need
to scarf a mess
[Music]
foreign